you know what the one thing had a hard
time with saying for the longest time
you ready this is gonna sound weird I
had a hard time saying I don't know
weird doesn't it we gotta we love saying
I know hey do you know what happened
with that one thing yeah I know I know I
heard about it do you know such-and-such
yeah of course I know I know who he is
have you watched at one movie I know I
think I did one time did you read this
book yeah I did I did so do you know
what happened I know and when we say I
know even though we don't know we're not
growing the day I started using the
magical words I don't know
I got smarter and wiser so today
practice saying I don't know and notice
how quickly you learn a thing or two
that you didn't know before